For the fifth time we present to you the human error calendar for the year,
12,021 this time. It's all about the journey of humanity.
Beginning, tens of thousands of years ago,
leading into the revolution of agriculture to ancient high civilizations
and the beginning of modern times culminating in a vision for our future.
You can get the limited edition now until we set out and then never again,
as always the calendar features 12 illustrated pages printed on high quality
paper in Europe and the U S and this year, the cover is especially shiny.
Not only does the calendar look great on walls and makes it easier to dream
about a glorious future and realize how far we've come as a species.
It's also the best way to support Kazaks.
The calendar enables us to put in the time our videos need and release them for
free for everyone. If you want,
you can get the Canada with a hoodie or infographic posters or plushy.
We've met a few deals for you.
Thank you so much to the thousands of people who get the calendar every year and
to the burbs who love what we try to do on this channel.
We wish you a happy year, 12,021,
and let's all hope that it will be less exciting than 12,020.
[Inaudible].